alex is with us in Ohio Alex what do you
think for hi Dave I'm thankful for the
fact that God chose to put me in a
Christian household in the best country
in the world very cool
how can I help today so my question is
about college on my second year out of 3
college this year I did pretty well on
scholarship so the whole year cost about
$6,000 I'm looking at about a three
thousand dollar check for next semester
I have six thousand dollars of student
loans and I have about fourteen and a
half thousand dollars thirteen and a
half of which is in checking and one
thousand is an emergency fund how old
are they so I guess my question is I'm
20 just turned 20 good for you and what
are you studying
agribusiness at Applied Economics okay I
would pay no nothing on the student
loans until you graduate and I would
pile up cash as high as you can pile it
to insure that you graduate with no more
loans that is rule one and you're gonna
have a good degree you're gonna be in a
good field you're gonna be able to make
a some good money so you'll come out get
the job and not the student loan out
immediately or if you've got some cash
left over when you come out after you
graduate just write the check and pay
them off but I wouldn't worry about
reducing the student loans there by
putting at risk that you might run out
of money before you get out of school
okay
I want you to get through schools that
free okay yeah and I guess also I was
looking to maybe get engaged in the next
six months or so cool that's definitely
in my future and so I guess just working
that into it is another factor and I
also have my all my income from next
summer which should be I don't know six
or eight thousand dollars mm-hmm so what
do you think about spending on the ring
I honestly have no clue okay I I don't
even like look at any prices anything
back it's like over in the future next
let's motor
well I'm old I bought a lot of diamonds
so I'll do my diamond speech for you
they don't go up in value that's crap
the only thing only value that they have
is the way that it makes that special
someone smile and that's the only value
that they have and so there is no
correlation between the size of the ring
and the likelihood of the marriage being
a success
none as a matter of fact if the ring is
too big there may be an inverse
correlation because they had unrealistic
expectations going in as to what life
was going to be like and you might be
marrying a princess so but you know so
you know have a nice ring something
that's a nice gift for this girl that
you love and that is wonderful but don't
buy it on the basis it's going to go up
in value it doesn't that's absolute
jewelry store crap I own a bunch of
diamonds that are on my wife and none of
them have gone up in value okay for a
long time and so it's nothing wrong with
that I'm not mad about it I'm not mad
about diamond it's okay to buy some but
they're not an investment okay so it's
an investment in the relationship the
second thing to know about them is that
they are other than furniture probably
have the highest margin of anything that
the consumer buys meaning that that
diamond at the retail jewelry store is
probably that jewelry jewel jewelry
store probably has half of that in it
and so if you know someone that knows a
little bit about diamonds an uncle a
parent someone that can help you with
the process to where you don't end up
accidentally buying a piece of glass and
get ripped off I would look at a diamond
broker I would look at maybe even a
high-end pawnshop and you might even if
you took the stone out of a ring you
bought there you might buy it for ten or
fifteen cents on the dollar of what you
would pay at the mall jewelry store
it'll blow your mind how good a deal you
can get if you shop around a little bit
now I don't want you to buy bad stone
and ugly stone I don't want you buy
something that you're not gonna be proud
of that she wears on any of that I'm not
saying that I'm not saying cheap out but
I'm just saying there's a lot of wiggle
room in this and don't just walk
the retail rabbit trail because you're
gonna overpay substantially and I would
think in your situation a thousand of
two thousand dollars is probably your
max okay you can always get another ring
later I got married 38 years ago on a
ring that was three it was 0.23 carat
less than 1/4 of a carat meaning you
can't even see the freaking diamond
that's so small okay now she doesn't
wear that now it's for sentimental
reasons sitting in the safe we kept it
we didn't get rid of it but obviously
she's got a headlight on her finger
these days but but but that that you
know this is all just for the
relationship that's all it's for it's
all for the fun of it so don't get
caught up in the value now I'm not
suggesting at Kubik and I'm not
suggesting a piece of glass and I'm not
suggesting a bad stone I'm just saying
there's a lot of wiggle room in this
world and for a thousand fifteen hundred
bucks you probably could buy a really
really nice stone if you'll watch what
you're doing even if you had to have it
remounted and so I just just learn a
little bit and be wise in this purchase
and don't get all caught up in the
standard retail finagling of this stuff